Good applications and
user interfaces, incorporate feedback
throughout the user experience.
If the user does not get enough
feedback they'll probably,
end up hating the application.
We should add a feature,
that explicitly notifies the user that
the system has responded to their input.
Flask provides a really simple
way to give feedback to a user.
Message Flashing is a feature that
will prompt a message to the user
immediately, after a certain
action has taken place, and
then disappear the next
time the page is requested.
We can use our templates to reveal
a flash message, wherever and
however we want,
from within the application.
To get started, let's import
flash from our Flask module.
Flashing works in Flask by using
a concept, called sessions.
This course does not go too,
in depth with sessions.
But just know that sessions are a way,
a server can store information across
multiple Web pages, to create a more
personalized user experience.
In the bottom of our project.pi file,
let's first add a secret key,
which flask will use to create
sessions for our users.
Normally, this should be
a very secure password,
if our application was live
on the Internet but for
development purposes, let's just
set our key to super_secret_key.
To flash the message
within our application,
we simply use the flash
function like this.
To get a hold of all of the flash
messages, we can use get_flash_messages,
which will also work from
within our templates.
So, from within my new menu item method,
I will create a flash message,
right after I call, session.commit.
I will add the message,
("new" menu item created!") now,
in my newmenuitem.html template,
I will add the following code.
If you are not familiar, with this
with construct in Python, don't worry.
It's just a block that does
some automatic clean-up,
when the block is exited, that we don't
really have to concern ourselves with.
If you are curious about
the with method in Python,
I will provide some resources
in the instructor notes.
The get_flashed_messages,
is returning an array of messages,
that's going to get stored in
this variable, called messages.
We then loop through the array of
message, if it's not empty, and
print it out to our HTML document
inside an Unordered List.
Now, when I save my code,
and try making a new item,
and flashed with a new confirmation
message on my main menu screen.